today on the matt wall show nearly 20
percent of america's restaurants have
closed permanently because of the
lockdowns and another 10 000 will be
added to the list to the list soon
we're told so the government has
intentionally decimated one of our most
important industries
how can anyone feel anything less than
rage over this also five headlines
including
the democrats uh setting to work to
enact their
radical pro-abortion agenda of course
and an israeli scientist makes a
stunning revelation involving
space aliens and something called the
galactic federation you're going to want
to hear about this if you haven't yet
big news plus
we will cancel an anti-gun mall santa
and much more today
on the matt walsh show
well you know in these very uncertain
times a lot a lot of uncertainty it's
important
never been more important to hedge your
invest investments with
something stable and real and solid
literally like gold
but the problem is that it's really
expensive and sort of out of it seems
like it's out of reach to just go out
and buy gold
i know it seemed like that for me and
for a lot of people you'd love to go buy
gold but it's just really expensive
well here's something new here's a
solution to that problem the price of
gold as it's been skyrocketing
uh it's not it is not now out of reach
anymore because of a company called acre
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30
a month you pay each month and once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they just ship it to your house simple
as that they ship it discreetly
and safely so you're gonna get uh you
you get your hands on on the gold bar
you're able to invest in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
so it's a lot more attainable for a lot
of people
acre designs their gold in california
sources their gold from one of the
largest mints in switzerland
and acre also also if you want to be a
little bit more ambitious and aggressive
you can sign up for their 100 per month
subscription
so they've got the 30 a month um as sort
of
the base level package but you could
also do 100 a month for their 5 gram
gold bar
whichever you want to do the point is
that you can
be an investor in gold you didn't think
you could but you can
here's what you got to do visit
getacregold.com
walsh and start investing in physical
gold today make sure you go
to the url because also acres will be
giving away a gold bar and if you want
to qualify for that giveaway which who
doesn't
you can tweet or post why you should be
the recipient and mention
at get underscore acre again that's get
acre gold dot com slash walsh and thank
you to acre gold
for supporting the show so time
magazine's latest issue echoes the
hyperbole found all over social media by
dubbing 2020 quote
the worst year ever i think most of the
people who say this
don't mean it literally i hope anyway
they don't mean it literally 2020
obviously is
not the worst year ever i mean any of
the years in the late 14th century
when the black plague was in the process
of wiping out half of europe's
population
were probably quite a bit worse than
this one or say 1862 when over 20 000
people were killed
in one day in just one battle of the
civil war that was antietam
uh that year was i'm guessing much more
challenging than this one the same goes
for 1861 1863 1864 or any of the years
leading up to and preceding the civil
war
in fact i bet if you were transported to
any year
prior to our modern age anywhere on
earth
you would within hours be begging for
the comfort and tranquility of america
circa the year of our lord 2020. i'm not
sure
what exactly was happening in say 1648
or 1234 or 1705 but i do know that the
nights were cold
survival was hard people probably didn't
smell very good
your children not all of them probably
would live to adulthood
and you would probably be dead before
50. so no
2020 is not the worst year ever not even
close to it and it's important to
establish that fact because
if we lose our sense of perspective then
we will not be able to
rationally evaluate our situation and
make good and coherent choices in fact
it is this lack of perspective this
inability to rationally evaluate
that has contributed greatly towards
making 2020 if not the worst year ever
at least a bad year and perhaps the
worst in several decades
it's what has scared people into
submitting to tyranny from the
government
and as far as that goes i think we can
say without
melodrama or hyperbole that what the
government has done over the past
several months
has been oppressive tyrannical and
capricious
to an extent unprecedented in our
lifetimes at least
this may not be the worst year literally
in history
but some of what has happened we have
never seen before
and it is very terrible indeed on that
end here's the latest a report from cnn
reporting
some real and important news for a
change i don't know if their normal
editors are on vacation or what to let
this slip through
but here's what the article says it says
about 17 of america's restaurants
have already permanently closed this
year with thousands more on the brink
according to a new report the national
restaurant association is publicly
pleading with congress to pass new
stimulus to help the industry
that has been damaged by the pandemic
the group said monday that 10
000 restaurants could close in the next
three weeks in addition to the 110
000 that have already shuttered in 2020.
now just to stop for a moment here
uh to really think about this
because you become numb to these numbers
after a while 110
000 restaurants have closed this year
110 000.
if i had told you in december of 2019
that in the following year over a
hundred thousand restaurants would be
closed
first of all you wouldn't believe me
second if you did believe me you would
think that i was describing
some kind of sudden economic apocalypse
some sort of
act of god coming out of the sky out of
the blue to destroy an entire industry
in one fell swoop
and you would be wrong in that
assumption this has been an intentional
deliberate targeted act decision
by our elected leaders now
a little bit more from cnn it says the
group released
results from a survey of 6 000
restaurant operators revealing that 87
percent of full-service restaurants
reported an average
36 percent drop in revenue and 83 expect
sales to be even worse
over the next three months as the virus
continues to lash the united states
sean kennedy executive vice president of
the group said in short the restaurant
industry simply cannot wait for relief
any longer
um he advocates for a quote true
compromise between the competing
democrat
and republican proposals and hopes for a
larger stimulus package of 2021 under
the incoming by the administration cnn
businesses dashboard tracking america's
recovery
shows a steep drop in restaurant
reservations down 70 percent during the
pandemic
they recovered in september have fallen
once again
a bipartisan stimulus proposal could be
unveiled this week it's unclear if the
extension of the paycheck protection
program
which the group wants will be included
now i said that cnn was reporting real
news for a change but
they can't help themselves of course as
usual the media reports that
even acknowledge the devastation will
always blame
lay the blame on the virus they lay the
blame of the economic
devastation on the virus well the virus
and donald trump
notice it says that the situation with
restaurants will get even worse
as the virus continues to lash the
united states but it's not the virus
doing this
the virus hasn't closed one single
restaurant our response to the virus has
done that
the distinction really matters because
it's not as though this was unavoidable
it's not as though
a virus had to demolish the restaurant
industry and put hundreds of thousands
of people
just from that industry alone out of
work there were
other ways of responding but we and by
we i mean they the politicians the
bureaucrats
chose this way they did this not the
virus
economically anyway they are the ones
lashing the united states not the virus
virus and now we're told that the only
solution
is to rely on the people who cause the
problem to begin with
we have to beg them to hammer out a deal
and pass a stimulus
that's the solution which yes they do
need to hammer out a deal and pass the
stimulus if they're going to put
millions of people out of work and shut
down millions of businesses it's their
responsibility to offer
some kind of compensation but this is a
band-aid at best
not a solution it's not what will save
the restaurant industry or any other
industry from full collapse
it's not what will save our economy or
reclaim our country or win back the
rights we've forfeited
the only way to really reclaim what has
been taken
is simply to take it back not to ask for
it to be given back but to take it
business owners should just open their
businesses
no matter what the restrictions and
ordinances say no matter what
gavin newsom or andrew cuomo thinks
about it
flip on the open side unlock the door
start doing business again
churches should open their doors invite
their congregations in
not waiting for permission from the
mayor or the sheriff or even their
bishop
if we're talking about a catholic church
people who want to
walk down the street without a mask
should simply walk down the street
without a mask
this is how america became a free
country in the first place
if you're waiting for the government to
give you permission to be free
you've already lost the only way is to
say
i am free i'm an american
and this is what i'm going to do try and
stop me
and maybe they will try and stop you
maybe they won't if enough people join
you
won't be able to stop you if people
don't join you
then even so at least you can know that
you did the right thing
the american thing you didn't take the
tyranny lying down
you chose at least to be free
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so a report here from breitbart as the
democrats get to work on enacting their
extreme pro-abortion agenda uh it says
on tuesday at 10 am house democrats led
by connecticut
representative rosa deloro will convene
a hearing well did convene now
hearing that will ignite their extreme
abortion agenda including their goal of
repealing the hyde amendment and forcing
american taxpayers to fund abortions
dolores tweeted the height amendment is
a discriminatory policy and one that is
routinely considered
every year as a legislative writer but
we are in a moment to reckon with the
norm
the hearing of the appropriations
subcommittee on labor health and human
services education related
agencies is titled the impact on women
seeking an abortion but are denied
because of an inability to pay
the lawyer said because of hyde too many
are hostages to their geography in the
coming congress the house spending bill
will not include it
uh then it goes on from there the height
amendment again
is as is referenced there um it it
prevents the federal government from
funding abortions
and um now we we already by the way
fund abortions effectively speaking
because we fund planned parenthood to
the tune of 500 bill
billion well maybe we'll get there soon
500 million dollars a year
and of course we're told oh that that
money isn't used to fund abortions
that's that that's that's separate money
well money is fungible okay you pour it
into the bucket
i mean you could pour water into one
side of a bucket and then some more
water to a different side
it's going to be hard to say which water
is which right it all kind of mixes
together
it's the same thing with money
so we already do but this is something
that would allow the government to
explicitly fund
abortion uh without even pretending that
they're not
and this is this of course we know is
the democrats agenda and i can tell you
one thing
if the republicans lose the senate i
mean if these if these
con artists down in georgia that are
telling republicans not to vote
if they get their way and the republican
and the and the republicans lose the
senate
then i mean we're looking at of course
left-wing radicalism across the board
but in the abortion industry in
particular
they're coming in with a vengeance on
the abortion
issue because
you know they feel like we have they
have to pay us back for the fact that
amy coney barrett was confirmed
and this is why it is so
infuriating to me that the republicans
had a chance
you know they had the house the senate
and the white house for two years
2016 to 2018. they had a chance
to make real progress and
they didn't do anything really
effectively in the end
number two uh if you want to be
thoroughly sickened here's a clip of new
york governor cuomo and virus is our
anthony
fauci flirting listen to this uh maybe
we enlist you
i'll do it with you we'll do an ad
telling new yorkers it's safe to take
the vaccine
to uh to you know put us together we're
like the
modern-day uh de niro and pacino you can
be which whenever
whichever you want you can be the de
niro or pacino
fauci and cuomo i'll give you a fun boy
who do you want to be de niro or pacino
which one do you want to remember i love
them
i don't want to insult one of the other
if they want i don't want to hurt the
feelings of the other yeah
who's the politician so funny these guys
couple of jokers having a lot of fun
with it
this is this is what gets me about cuomo
is just how flippant he is he's been
this entire time
he's having a great time i mean andrew
cuomo
is having a great time with the
chronovirus he's selling books
he's doing he's given his you know he's
given speeches he's doing his press
conferences
he's joking around with anthony fauci
he's going on doing segments with his
brother
on cnn they're making jokes about his
big ears with the big prop
uh q-tip he's just having a hell of a
time
while he pretends to be taking it
seriously which of course he isn't
number three this is from the new york
post it says a mom of three
who was cleared of knowingly having sex
with a boy who was only 14
now plans to capitalize on her notoriety
by peddling images and videos on a
raunchy website according to a report
um taya vincent is her name she says
she's thinking of doing an
of starting up an only fan's account
now taya vincent and
only fans a subscription site where
people go for pornography basically
uh taya vincent 32 years old admitted to
initiating sex with
a 14 year old boy after inviting him
and his buddy into her home this is in
the uk
now the mom insisted she thought that he
was 16 which is the legal age of consent
in in the uk
um she uh had told the gloucester crown
court i think it's pronounced gloucester
it was a gloucester i don't know
that it was only after they were
finished in bed that the youngster
panicked and convinced
confessed his tender age but vincent was
ultimately cleared after the court was
told
how the boy had lied about his age so
they put they put the fault on on the
kid
and now she goes free and she's thinking
of starting an only
fan's account and
a couple of things here first of all as
usual with the reporting on these
stories
and of course you notice this whenever
it's a
a woman particularly if it's an
attractive woman
who quote has sex with a child
that's how it's reported it's reported
as well she had sex with a 14 year old
or even sometimes you'll see the phrase
sex romp
i remember seeing that recently i think
was actually a fox news headline
uh it was a a woman had a had a sex romp
with a with one of her students a
teacher
now this is not a sex romp this is not
having sex this is rape
that's what we call it and if she was a
man that's how it be reported
so and that's the other thing we see
here of course is this is this enduring
double standard when it comes to these
kinds of issues
that people just the courts don't take
it as seriously i mean you you reverse
the genders here
let's say this was a 32 year old man
having sex with a 14 year old girl
he'd be in prison wouldn't he wouldn't
be starting any you know he wouldn't be
going into porn
and people wouldn't speaking of being
flippant people wouldn't be as flippant
in response to it
this is even the most supposedly
enlightened feminist they still have
this double standard
no one can explain why you know why is
it
not as big of a deal for a woman to do
this to a boy
i i think it's as big of a deal i don't
see any difference
but the the reaction from the public is
oh yeah the t
when the teachers do it that's why we
have there is a real epidemic
in the public school system of
teachers assaulting sexually assaulting
students
but it doesn't get the same kind of
attention as say the epidemic that we
had in the catholic church
part of that of course is the media
hates the catholic church but loves the
public school system so they're trying
to protect it
but also a big part of it is that a lot
of the high profile cases
of teachers sexually assaulting their
students it's female teachers doing it
and the public just says ah i don't know
not as big of a deal
no one can explain why
i would say regardless of gender if
you're an adult
sexually preying upon a child you're a
scumbag equally
man or woman that is my controversial
take on that
number four um here are two mostly
unrelated headlines i'm just going to
read the headlines to
to you see if you can pick up on on sort
of the game they're playing here
first this is from the ap it says
coronavirus pandemic has led to an
unprecedented surge of children and
teens in psychiatric crisis
that's straining an already stretched
hospital system
so we see here again the same thing that
that cnn did with the
with the economic crisis and restaurants
being shut down saying the coronavirus
pandemic
has caused this unprecedented surge
no it's not the chronovirus pandemic
doing that it's that we're taking these
kids
i'll tell you what's doing it we're
taking these kids we're locking them in
their homes
they're not going to school they're not
seeing their friends you know they can't
even go to a playground for some reason
even now you go to a i saw a playground
recently it was it was
it was there's caution tape wrapped
around it
is there any indication any evidence
that playgrounds are vectors of
transmission i don't think so
so we're not letting them get outside
the house we're locking them in
and um and also we're scaring the hell
out of them
making them wear masks everywhere
i mean they don't they don't understand
what's happening especially the younger
kids
that's why you have a psychiatric crisis
again it's the response it's not the
virus itself
and then here's one here's a good one
from the hill this is a headline from
the hill
it says mostly white crowd gathers
outside of home of black ohio
ohio councilwoman to protest public
health order
mostly white crowd so we've heard of the
mostly peaceful crowd
now here's the mostly white crowd and so
these were
anti-lockdown protesters who were
protesting someone who was pushing a
lockdown
and but here's what the media does
because i'll tell you what they would
they would love it if these
anti-lockdown protesters would be
violent
they would love that and they're really
disappointed that none of these
these protests never turn violent
because these are mostly conservatives
and conservatives don't engage in
political violence that's a left-wing
thing it's not a conservative thing
so because they're not getting the
violence they want instead they said
well we'll just go to plan b here smear
him as racist
call it a mostly white crowd point out
the racial dynamic
of course they don't go anywhere with it
they don't they don't they don't then
say
you know explicitly accuse these people
of being racist because they don't have
to
it's the old dog whistle that we're
always told about
number five finally this is huge news
i'm glad we could finally get to this
um listen to this report this is also
from the new york post
if you haven't heard this i feel like
this really matters
i don't know it says space aliens have
reached an agreement with the u.s
government to stay mum on the
experiments they conduct on earth
as well as their secret base on mars
until mankind is ready to accept them
this according to the former head of
israel's space program
which he he claimed in an interview with
the jerusalem post
or rather the jewish press i should say
the jewish press
goes on to unspool the tangled web which
claims the involvement of president
trump
and interplanetary diplomacy
uh it says trump was on the verge of
revealing the alien's existence
but the aliens in the galactic
federation are saying wait
let people calm down first he said
they don't want to start mass hysteria
they want to first make us
sane and understanding and so it's it's
a really interesting part you go to the
jewish press and read that i would
recommend reading the whole report
it's actually very extensive and they go
into great detail from this guy
uh what's his name i didn't even give
you his name it's important to know
uh hayam ished i mean this is a former
high-ranking guy i mean a scientist
saying there's a galactic federation
aliens have been to earth
they're here right now donald trump
knows about it hasn't
was wanted to tell us apparently donald
trump is in
in communication with the galactic
federation i don't know if there's a
special room down in the white house
where you know there's a a big
tv screen he can and he can have like a
zoom calls
with the galactic federation somewhere
out in the in the galaxy
uh but he was going to tell us and the
galactic federation said no no they're
not ready don't tell them
i'll tell you what um
i choose to believe this there's no
reason to believe it
it's pretty clear this guy just is going
insane
but i choose to believe it and
assimilate it into my worldview
and because of that my life just got
like 35 percent more interesting
and also i got 35 crazier but i think
that's a trade worth making
as somebody pointed out on twitter uh i
i think the the least
believable part of this i mean there are
a few parts of it that maybe
strain credibility a little bit the
least believable part by far
is that donald trump knows about aliens
and hasn't told us
was able to keep his mouth his mouth
shut about it that's the part i mean i'm
almost
you can almost buy all of it even the
galactic federation part
until you get to that you say no there's
no way
trump to his credit trump if he knew
about aliens you know he would tell us
and that is also for me maybe the most
disappointing thing about trump's
presidency
is that it basically confirms that the
government doesn't know about aliens
because trump would have told us for
sure he would have at least hinted at it
very strongly as he would say um
and uh also another side note
this does sound a little bit like
scientology doesn't it galactic
federation
isn't that a scientology thing so tom
cruise john travolta they were right all
along
all right before we get to our daily
cancellation one other thing kind of a
bonus story here
um you know i'm a critic of hollywood i
tend to hate most of the movies and
shows that it produces
but i have to say this new trailer which
just came out
i'm very hyped about this i think this
has the makings potentially
of a true cinematic classic uh in my
view
and uh one that will stand the test of
time i'm sure and it gives us all
something to look forward to
here's the trailer watch this
what the hell are you doing a lifetime
original mini movie
you don't answer my proposal and now
you're not answering my call
i think i'm falling for the new chef
jessica is falling for harlan the cook
leave jessica alone and skip he has a
secret recipe that's going to change the
world
harlan claims to have some secret recipe
a secret recipe
spare me we all have our secrets
if you marry my daughter i promise
there'll be more long weekends in your
future
mom i have to tell you something we have
a problem
secret's out chicken man i'll take care
of this
ruining everything just kill him already
where the hell are you harlan sanders
the new chef
mario lopez is colonel sanders in a
recipe for seduction
wow premieres uh at noon of course
lifetime premiering in the middle of the
week at noon
so if you don't have a job um that that
gives you something to look forward to
i think i think this is great kind of an
origin story for colonel sanders
i'd like to see the origin story of arby
next
which of course is the the best fast
food restaurant hands down
so i mean a lot of crap coming out of
hollywood but that's something that we
can look forward to
anyway before we get to the daily
cancellation if you're uh
scrambling right now and not sure what
you know maybe you've got someone an
important person in your life you
haven't gotten them a christmas gift yet
you're not sure what to get them you
want to get them something
meaningful well let me suggest paint
your life you cannot go wrong with paint
your life
you're going to be the hit you're going
to have the favorite present it's always
good to know that you gave the favorite
present
if you want to give a truly meaningful
gift then paintyourlife.com is the way
to go you can get a professional
hand-painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price
all you got to do is just send any
picture whether it's yourself your
children
family a special place a cherished pet
whatever you want to do
or you could combine photos into once
you could send them a bunch of photos
and they can create basically say a
family portrait of family members that
never had a chance to meet
or for a you know a picture taking
occasion that had to be canceled
this year uh that's another another
thing a lot of people are doing with
paint your life
whatever you however however you want to
approach it you can choose from a team
of world-class artists and work with
them until every detail is perfect
uh it's a very hands-on process and you
know they're going to be
consulting with you every step of the
way because they know that this is your
picture this is important to you and so
they want to make sure they get it right
to your specifications
and here's the great thing you can get
the hand-painted painted portrait back
in about three weeks
it's a lot quicker than you think it
will be perfect holiday gift so
paintyourlife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded guaranteed
and right now as a limited time offer
you get 20 off your painting
that's right 20 off and free shipping
you don't want to lose
your chance to to grab this offer so to
get this special offer text the word
matt to 64 000 that's matt to 64
000 text matt m-a-t-t to 64 000 paint
your life celebrate the moments that
matter most
um another gift you can give yourself
this year
is a daily wire membership and also
our new leftist tears tumbler very very
snazzy
it actually says that on my copy i'm
supposed to call it very very snazzy
and it is no no lie about that and this
is
another thing you can get along with
becoming a daily wire member
now a lot of great perks are gonna are
you you already get a lot of great perks
if you're a daily wire member
but uh there's even more on the way as
we get into the new year the michael
knowles show is now five days a week
we're adding the entire prageru catalog
we've got the canis owens
show uh candace owens prageru show is
available now in the daily wire
but uh she's also joining the daily wire
she'll be here in nashville for a live
show
we're building a new investigative
journalism team we're gonna be doing
movies
all kinds of stuff and we've also got um
merchandise
over at dailywire.com subscribe um
merchandise like for example these
christmas ornaments
uh we've got a lot of we've got
merchandise that's better than the
christmas ornaments
but i do have to tell you about the
christmas ornaments because they're not
sold out yet so i have to keep on
talking about them
and in fact i don't know who's bought
them i could tell you that my wife
bought these christmas ornaments
she knows how much i love them she
bought two boxes
and i i said i'm pretty sure we could
probably get them for free maybe not
now it is me after all i should be able
to get it for free she wanted to buy
them anyway
and so they're gonna be hanging on my
christmas tree if they're gonna be
hanging on my christmas tree they should
be hanging on yours too
text christmas to 83400
to get your tree decorated with these
adorable christmas elves and the
christmas ornaments they're going fast
sure uh so get yours now now let's get
to our daily cancellation
today i'm canceling santa claus uh at
least one iteration of santa claus
i'm hoping hoping that this santa is not
the real santa the one i'm cancelling
an imposter we might assume was at a
mall somewhere in the country when he
appeared to dash a young boy's christmas
dreams
to tragic effect listen
what do you want for christmas
what else would you like lots of other
toys there's legos
bicycles there's cars and trucks
what do you think
[Music]
what do you think
so the boy wants a nerf gun for
christmas
what boy doesn't want a nerf gun for
christmas and santa says no
can't bring you guns even nerf guns from
the way he phrases it it does make you
wonder whether this guy
actually thinks he really is santa if he
starts talking to the boy about what he
can bring trying to give other options
he doesn't seem to realize that in fact
he's not santa
the real santa has no anti-gun bias as
evidenced by the fact that i got toy
guns for christmas
every year as a child also the real
santa's 1700 years old
you'd think he's far too old at this
point to have gone woke on us
uh you know already now this santa then
is just a guy in a red suit and his job
is to
listen to the child's request answer in
a vague affirmative
oh i'll talk to my elves about that or
whatever and then take a picture
that's his entire job it's his job just
to do that his job is not to deliver
lectures or start telling the kid
what he can and can't have for christmas
the parents waiting in line
aren't paying all that money for a
christmas present consult with a guy in
a red suit
they're paying for smiles and christmas
cheers and a picture a picture that is
already weird enough this year because
santa has to sit six feet away
if you saw on the video clip there so
that in the picture
you know you have the kid in the
foreground and then some random fat dude
hovering in the background
smiling weirdly trust me we've already
done this with our kids
and my wife's insistence the picture
comes out as bizarre and unnerving as it
sounds
and everyone has to wear masks at least
the the santa one we did
santa's wearing masks the kids have to
wear masks so everybody's masked you
can't see anyone smile
santa's just sort of vaguely in the
distance
back there and everyone's just standing
there masked
it's the creepiest weirdest thing
but speaking of the parents you have to
wonder why none of them
stepped up to put this man in his place
why didn't any of them go over and tell
him to know his role and shut his mouth
to quote a man who has also recently
been canceled on this show
well it goes back to what we discussed
yesterday during this segment
people stand by meekly and just film
everything or take pictures
becoming passive observers in situations
where they should be active participants
a mall santa is being a bully to a young
child
there are not many times in life when
you can yell at santa and not be the
jerk in the situation
but this was one such occasion and all
of the adults in the vicinity apparently
squandered it
somehow so they're cancelled too
as for the mall santa he sadly is not
alone in apparently thinking that
there's something wrong or troubling
about boys playing with toy guns
this is a common hang-up that people
have and increasingly so in our confused
and anti-male society
it goes along with the general hang-up
about boys being aggressive rough
violent everywhere a boy turns he's met
by forces wishing to domesticate and
feminize him
now on the list of those threats amal
santa doesn't quite make the top ten but
it's a sad statement that the efforts
are so pervasive at this point
as to encompass even mall santas here's
here's the reality boys
have a natural aggression a natural
tendency towards violence this is good
it's who they are it's who they were
made to be
now you can't let those tendencies
develop entirely on their own all
children must learn to be civilized but
you also can't suppress them or treat
them as symptomatic of some kind of
disease
the goal is to harness a boy's innate
aggressiveness
part of that process an important part
maybe even the most important part for a
kid
is through play the boy pretends to be a
superhero he pretends to be a soldier a
police officer a cowboy
toy guns will often be involved in these
kinds of games he's learning that
violence can be good which is true
it can but it has to be violence and
service of good
to protect and defend heroic violence
sports also play
a crucial role here now on the other end
if a kid gets caught up in you know
movies
shows games that are overly gory and
nihilistic and not appropriate for his
age
and is too exposed to that and
fascinated by it that he's going to
start to learn the wrong things about
violence have the law
the wrong relationship with violence and
that can have a very detrimental effect
on his growth
and that's why the goal is always to
embrace who the child is help him to
harness his innate tendencies and to
guide him in the right direction which
means yes
let him play with nerf guns now perhaps
i've delivered a
more serious analysis of the mall santa
video than was necessary
but even so the point remains it is good
for boys to have nerf guns
and even better nowadays because it
means they're going to be on their feet
moving around physically playing rather
than sitting on a couch and moving only
their thumbs
so for that reason the mall santa is
canceled
and really all mall santas are canceled
this year because a socially distant
santa is just not the same it turns out
all the adults in that video are
canceled
the only one not cancelled is uh is the
child who i hope
still gets his nerf gun in the end
that's going to do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
ted cruz offers to make the trump team's
arguments at the supreme court president
trump speeds up executions for death row
inmates
and a killjoy liberal santa makes a kid
cry
check it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]